the jurogan experience i mean i think
that is kind of
a root of anxieties like modern life
like things trigger fight or flight that
shouldn't necessarily you know it's like
stress at work and your boss or whatever
and it like triggers that same thing
yes but um yeah it is true that that in
my life at least
the things that trigger fight or flight
are like legitimate life or death sorts
of situations where it's like oh you you
know you are about to fall off a cliff
or like oh
you know like the storm is coming and
you're out in the middle of nowhere and
you're like i'm about to get
worked you know it's like right like
typically when i feel that kind of major
anxiety it's like for a real reason and
um i mean it is interesting yeah i mean
it is it is appropriate that way
it's like it's like it's like the
correct outlet for that kind of stress
it really does completely make sense as
to and also most of the guys that i've
met that do what you do
and i don't know if they've met anybody
that does exactly what you do but
guys that climb a lot they're pretty
chill yeah
it's a pretty well dude i think part of
that is because you get
worked by nature so often that then when
you're in sort of normal life everything
feels pretty relaxed because you're kind
of like
oh i'm physically comfortable i'm fed
i'm hydrated i'm
like you know my body is fine i'm not
about to just get hammered by
by nature you know yeah like yeah that's
my philosophy about
really difficult exercise it's really
important because it makes other things
seem easy and the stresses of regular
i think we have just like a standard
base level of stress
and when you artificially impose a
higher base level electively like
whether it's through climbing or other
kind of exercise
totally whatever you're doing it makes
the rest of life
seem easier seem easy yeah dude i had a
earlier this year
there was a winter storm warning for
vegas it does snow in vegas sometimes in
the mountains especially like get
get snow there's a winter storm warning
for this like storm coming through
and i'd climbed like 20 days in a row
basically or something and i wanted to
use the storm day to try to hike this
one section of the traverse that i'm
trying to do
of all these peaks i figured i would
like take advantage of a non-climbing
day to do the one walking section to
like figure out where the route goes
and so i went out in this crazy storm
and when i started it was like snowing a
little and i was like
in crazy wind it's really cold and i was
trying out these new like waterproof
layers just to see how actually i wanted
to try them out before the jungle to see
if they'd be good jungle layers
and um and so i go up into the mountain
anyway long story short i get completely
worked it turns out
visibility is nothing i didn't know
where i was going i get lost in the
mountains it
and it wound up being basically too
difficult of terrain to travel through
uh in the snow like uh because i'd sort
of taken it for granted but in red rock
on those mountains you
you walk on these like exposed sandstone
slabs all the time but when you cover
them in like six inches of snow it's
like
really kind of horrifying you can't just
like walk up the slabs anymore it's like
now
a total tobogganing death trap where
you're gonna like slide down
you know so i was like anyway so i go up
quite a ways eventually i just had to
give up and like turn around but i'm now
you know 2500 feet like
up this mountainside and then i turned
around
and then it all was way more socked in i
couldn't even see my tracks anymore
because everything's like
filled in and visibility is nothing and
so i had like a garmin watch on so i
kept like looking a little track of my
watch being like
am i to the left or the right of the
track that i came up you know like no
idea where i am full mountain's on
keep falling down and you know there's
like you're falling
yeah but like sliding over things or
tripping on rocks it's really steep
hillside with like
and you're stepping through you know say
six or eight inches of fresh powder but
underneath it's still like loose rocks
and cactuses and things like that so
it's like
you know the terrain is it's not like a
snow base or something right like you're
just
stepping through it and falling over
anyway so i fell into cactuses a bunch
of times
and so the thing is i was totally
hypothermic completely wet
totally worked and my hand had all these
cactus thorns in it
and my other hand was too numb to like
manipulate anything
so i went up like biting the biggest
thorns out and then just left the rest
of them because it's just
i just i just couldn't use my hands and
just keep staggering down the mountain
anyway eventually i like made it back to
the car made it back to the house and i
had my wife pull all the thorns out
because i like i couldn't really use my
hands i was so worked
but i was kind of like but that was like
my rest day adventure you know what i
mean that's like
i mean it turned out being it turned out
being way more apparently yeah
yeah i mean i was hoping that it was
going to go better in that and it didn't
really work out
but that is kind of the point that when
you take on that elective love you know
i was like i had a goal that i wanted to
piece together this section of a hike
didn't work out that way i wound up you
know building a bunch of character
instead
but you know you're just like that's
just a normal day out you know it's like
when you're adventuring in the mountains
sometimes
sometimes those winter storm advisories
actually happen you know
it's just easy living in the desert
you're like it'll be fine it'll be fine
and then you're like no
it was not fine it was totally crunk
that's pretty crazy and that
that does speak to what we're saying
like if you're doing that kind of [ __ ]
yeah and that's just like a normal day
you know like that's not even like the
crazy
like oh i thought i was gonna die i was
just like i was just deeply
uncomfortable and like sort of on
edge for you know a while catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience